with sassy night service about to begin
it's time to get this Shack in order
it's pretty obvious that the business is
in dire straits and that's real that's
the truth
watching you guys over the last couple
of days you actually treat it like it's
your [ __ ] home chilled relaxed and
this lady here you talk to her
almost as it is your mum and that really
has to stop if this is gonna go any
further and if it doesn't work none of
you out of business they lie before it's
gone all of you guys are out of a
[ __ ] job you've got no work so when
it's that far down we really have to dig
deep and come up with sensible ideas and
tonight I'm gonna ask you to stay out
the kitchen okay if you've got so much
to sell yeah and you you know [ __ ]
good cook thank you so Sherita let him
cook I'm gonna nanometre yeah yeah have
to pass the reins over now and if you
don't break away from this stove I swear
to god the business is gonna close and
let them do the job you [ __ ] pay
their money for okay yeah yep I'm gonna
go put some makeup Charita Street
hustling has secured a fully booked
restaurant tonight if we're gonna get
through it
we need to get this kitchens working
like an efficient one old machine
time to whip up a bit of professionalism
into these boys not just but yourself
good evening downstairs shree to slip
effortlessly into the role of the
hostess with the mostest rhymes taking
this first decision of the head chef
precooked buffalo wings are off the menu
from now on they're being cooked to
order well almost the rest of the food's
going out just as sherita's always done
it hot food complete uninspiring and
you're breaking meatloaf but let's not
try to run